how is the strongest demon sir who
crushed and embarrassed moves on and
gave him PTSD related to tangible what
is the big comedo family secret who
exactly is his look-alike sumioshi how
does zenitsu fit into the Commodore
family tree because he does who does
Tundra end up with and what are his kids
and their kids like I'll be answering
all of these questions and more as I
fully explain the Commodore family tree
from the earliest ancestor to the final
ones way past tanjiro so make sure to
stay tuned for that join the demon
slaying fan by subscribing and hitting
that notification Bell to turn on all
notifications so you don't miss future
one piece videos and updates the
Commodore history starts with Tanja look
alike sumiyoshi kamado who looks like
Tundra because he is his ancestor the
mangaka likes to make relatives look
exactly alike sometimes and this isn't
the only Tundra look-alike we'll run
into in this video in the anime we
recently met Sumi Yoshi through a
flashback he was with yorichi tsugikuni
the strongest demons are in history who
gave muzon PTSD by crushing him so bad
yorichi was watching their child for
sumiyoshi and his wife suyako it's
revealed that the kamado family owes
yorichi their lives as sumiyoshi
explains if it wasn't for yorichi they
wouldn't be alive anymore and his child
wouldn't have been born sumioshi offers
to tell his children and grandchildren
about yorichi but yorichi says that it
isn't necessary sumioshi is a mere
charcoal seller as he says and as we
know the kamado family continues to work
in that trade up to tanjira's time
unfortunately this flashback is cut
short but we find out more later yurichi
explains to sumioshi that yorichi was
born with special strength for the
purpose of defeating muzon but he was
lacking in the end he failed because of
that many more people will die and that
pains him and yes even though he did in
a sense beat muzon by completely
outclassing him he couldn't finish him
off because muzon escaped and kept
running from him until yorichi died of
old age still even though he was hard on
himself and felt like a failure he
hopefully realized that it wasn't all
for nothing when sumioshi's child sumire
wish for a hug he hugged the trial that
he saved from a demon and lifted her up
as the child laughed the usually stoic
urichi began to cry clearly moved and
hugged the child again although he
couldn't save his own wife and child
hopefully he realized that he saved this
child it's thanks to him that she could
be joyful like this so his life wasn't
really for nothing suiko stumbles upon
this scene carrying another baby on her
back and since she saw him crying she
tried to cheer him up later yorichi
shows suyako the sword forms for sun
breathing after she asks to see them
sumiyoshi watched him carefully burning
them into his memory so not one escaped
it's going to be very useful that he did
this because of ancestral inherited
memory so that tonjo can access later
sumioshi would go on to pass this sun
breathing down through the dance of the
fire god it was after he illustrated The
Sword forms that yurichi gave Sumi Yoshi
his ear ornaments aka the khalafuda
earrings that Tundra wears that are so
iconic when it comes to Demon Slayer
sumioshi realized that yorichi would
never come back but now at least he had
the ear ornaments and Sun breathing to
pass down through the Commodore family
tree so even though yorichi wasn't
technically a comma though he's
definitely a Commando in spirit he had a
big impact on the family from saving it
to leaving his earrings and Sun
breathing with them eventually through a
dance of the fire god and sumioshi's
ancestral memories Tundra will be able
to beat muzon once and for all albeit
with help so yurichi really did set the
groundwork for beating muzon through the
Commodore family even if he didn't
succeed in doing it during his lifetime
as yurichi left Sumi Yoshi said once
again that he saved their lives and so
they will carry on his legacy and they
did through the Commodore family tree
Once Sumi Yoshi makes it clear that
yorichi's life wasn't meaningless and
that he'll pass down the ornaments and
Sun breathing yurichi actually smiles as
he says thank you tanjiro similarly
thanks to Richie eventually saying that
if it weren't for yorichi he'd never
have been born yorichi and sumiyoshi
lived over 300 years before the main
Story begins we know that thanks to
yorichi the family tree kept growing
uninterrupted until we get to Tundra's
dad tanjuru kamado who married kie
kamado and had a whopping six kids
tanjiro nazuko Takeo hanako Shigeru and
rokuta but before getting into the kids
let's take a look at tanjuro many have
compared him with yorichi and some even
thought that he was the same person
before the truth was revealed in the
manga some people still think they're
the same person in my comment section
unfortunately tanjuro became sick and
frail but he nevertheless seemed to be
the embodiment of yorichi's teachings he
knew hinokami AKA Dance of the fire god
well it even taught it to tanjiro
similarly he wore the hanafuda earrings
notably he also had a sort of scar on
his forehead where Tanja did too and
where yarichi had the Demon Slayer Mark
to me at least it's a sign that tanjuro
probably could have awakened the
demonstrator mark like tanjiro under the
right circumstances we get flashbacks of
tanjuro doing the dance of the fire god
tanjiro our protagonist is told that
their family works with fire so in order
to keep them safe they offer a dance and
prayers to hinokami the fire god at the
start of each year although the origins
of the dance have been lost namely that
it came from yorichi it is still in the
family and there to help against muzon
when the time is right once tanjiro
asked his father how he can dance so
long in the cold and keep in mind he's
sick and dying at this point tanjura the
father explains there's a special way of
breathing that lets you never get tired
no matter how long you move if tanjuro
actually reached this point which it
seems like he did he was very Advanced
indeed since even tanjiro and the
hashira can't dance slash fight forever
Tanja the father told tanjiro the son to
wear the earrings when he does the
kagura aka the dance and that he should
wear them always so he doesn't lose them
he makes tanjiro promise later during
his fight against akasa tanju remembers
that his father was like a plant not
temperamental at all and always calm in
other words this is the selfless state
that helps tanjiro finally out class
upper Moon 3 akasa Tundra remembers how
his father performed the dance from
Sunset to Sunrise which if you think
about it prepares the dancer to keep
fighting muzon until the sun comes up
and defeats Him Father tanjuro admitted
to his son that he had trouble with the
dance when he was young but ironically
even though he's sick now it's easier
for him to do it because he doesn't make
unnecessary movements he tells tanjiro
what's important is proper breathing and
control making the most efficient
movements to exercise the most strength
he even reveals that he can see the
transparent world and is able to open
and close blood vessels and muscles as
quickly and easily as blinking this by
the way is beyond hashra level stuff and
just in case you thought tanjudo's skill
didn't apply in fighting we get a scene
of tanjuro beating a giant-sized bear
with a small ax like it was nothing this
was only 10 days before he died so you
can imagine he was very sick he made two
cuts in the Blick of an eye to take off
its head and tanjiro couldn't even
follow them father tanjuro was truly a
legend that seemed to have more skill
than tanjiro and the hashira but
unfortunately he became sick before he
could confront muzon as a Demon Slayer
nevertheless as the Commodore before him
did he passed on what he learned to his
son the best he could and tanjiro even
if he wasn't as skilled as tanjuro learn
from him the dance of the fire God as
well as how to see the transparent world
and the selfless State eventually
luckily he had strong hashira and
friends to help him make up for any Gap
he had left in skill tanjiro himself
when he faces muzon admits that he
doesn't have yorichis or his father's
skill but nevertheless he knows the
dance aka the sun breathing forms and
even knows that they must be connected
and repeated although all of tanjudo's
younger children were killed tanjiro the
one he taught Sun breathing and nezuko
were still left now back to the muzon
fight where the whole yorichi influence
on the Commodore family reaches its
climax muzan realizes that tanjiro has
turned his Black Blade red like yorichi
did before him but he also notes that
yorichi's red blade and swings were much
more formidable thus he thinks he'll be
fine until he realized that the poison
he ingested through tamio sells is
slowing him down as well preventing him
from finishing tantro off this is what
I'm talking about when I say that it is
a team effort and that the team makes up
for any lack of skill tanjiro may have
compared to yurichi or even his father
even yurichi's old attacks come into
play as they continue to burn muzon's
flesh after all of these centuries after
being sufficiently weakened yurichi's
attacks appear visibly on muzon's body
helping tanjiro and everyone see where
he's most vulnerable after a lot of
teamwork they end up holding off muzon
long enough for the sun to come up and
do its work finally the Commodore family
has completed their mission of finishing
what yorichi started even if it took
over 300 years but that's not the end of
the family tree since Tundra gets
married and has children and they have
children and so on and so on more
specifically Tundra ends up with kanal
and they have children and nezuko ends
up with zanitsu and they have children
chapter 205 is is a big time skip that
takes us all the way to modern day Tokyo
where we meet tanjura's descendants
Kanata who looks like the male version
of kanau and sumihiko who like sumiyoshi
is another tangible clone and it's nice
that he even has the Sumi in his name as
well karata says what he thinks right
away and has no girlfriend we're told in
the extended ending while sumihiko
dreams to work in a zoo and he likes
slow lorises four of nezuko enzymes
whose descendants are featured in the
extended ending including Toko who looks
like nazuko yoshitero who looks like a
black-haired zanitsu and their two
younger sisters one of whom looks like
zanitsu the eyebrows and everything and
she's adorable Toko wants to be a
prosecutor and make sure yoshiteru
studies while yoshiteru got hit by a
truck while protecting his sister he's a
good guy on the inside we're told but
tends to be very unfair which sounds a
lot like zanitsu in fact in chapter 205
yoshitero can be seen reading a book
titled the legend of zenitsu and crying
Toko calls it great grandfather novel of
Lies since peaceful times have led
people to assume that demons never
existed we also see on the last page
that the current Commodore residence has
the hanafuda earrings featured on the
wall and a photograph of tundra nezuko
and the rest who succeeded in ridding
the world of demons so I really like
that they still held on to yorichi's
earrings after all this time in the
extended ending we also get sumihiko
dreaming about his grandma and how she
used to tell him about his great great
grandpa and grandma who worked really
hard to defeat all those human eating
demons so everything's okay now it's
hard for us to picture Tundra as a great
great grandpa but it's nice to see how
far the family tree has come from
sumioshi as far as named ancestors go
all the way to here the secret influence
of yorichi and his son breathing helped
this family of cool sellers save the
world and that influence is still
present and honored by the earrings on
the Commodore wall but that's just the
tip of the iceberg and if little known
demons share secrets interest you then
you won't want to miss my 101
demonstrator secrets you didn't know
video link on screen right now and in
the description I'll see you there